pour un chasseur quelle est la
différence entre un sanglier et un chien
ça mon Lolo ça va très bien bon c'est
suivi toi tu crois tu crois qu'il tombe
bien
quand je suis en train de faire des
pâtes j'entends des déclics de photos
fais gaffe
gaffe on a une nouvelle adresse ah oui
oh là là alors attendez oui alors on a
une nouvelle adresse pour les mails
alors il faut d'abord c'est très très
simple vous allez voir vous essayez déjà
vous prenez un stylo vous prenez 20
minutes déjà
alors déjà vous allez sur France 2.fr ok
France 2.fr quand vous êtes sur France 2
vous endormez c'est normal prenez à
gauche et là vous arrivez à Tout le
monde en parle le site tout le monde en
parle bon quand vous êtes sur tout le
monde en parle vous allez sur Laurent
Baffie enfin c'est une image
vous cliquez vous cliquez voilà voilà
est-ce que c'est clair France 2.fr tout
le monde en parle Laurent Baffie vous
pourriez aller directement à Laurent
Baffie non ok non voilà alors j'ai pas
beaucoup de
bruit
j'en ai deux trois je les balance quand
même pour un chasseur quelle est la
différence entre un sanglier et un chien
environ 12 pastilles
mais bon je la fais quand même quel est
le poids idéal pour une belle-mère
2 kg avec l'urne
elle est méchante
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu